we talked about the dissemination of
information being a force of convergence
on the global scale but what on what
about on the individual scale we're
talking about not when we're talking
about knowledge dissemination on an
individual scale we're really talking
about education on some level so once
again this is a topic very close to my
heart so let's just go through a few
thought experiments here so in general
you have and you have income income and
that income in order to produce it you
need capital you need capital and you
need you need labor for example if
you're running a farm you need land and
you need animals and you need some
equipment but you also need people to
run the equipment and manage the farm if
you're running a software company you
need a building you need computers you
need servers I guess as computers as
well but you need people to program the
computers and to sell the and to sell
the software and to develop it and
whatever else so these are the two
things that you need in order to produce
output which you would recognize in
terms of income but then the question is
how does that income get split doesn't
how much of it goes to the capital and
how much goes to labor and the idea here
is is that if you have dissemination of
knowledge and if knowledge work becomes
more and more and more valuable so if
knowledge work so let me put a little
little aura around this so this is the
aura of knowledge if this is knowledge
work and it's less and less of a
commodity then maybe labor has more
leverage here on the other hand if you
have these hugely capital intensive
industries where labor is kind of this
monotonous unskilled work then maybe
capital has more of the leverage now
let's just think about and and Piketty
tends to be a little dismissive of this
happening on a large scale he says it
might be happening in pockets it might
be happening in pockets in terms of you
know managers and finance or maybe in
certain industries like the software
industry but in his mind this isn't this
knowledge dissemination
isn't going to make Labor important
enough in order to offset this hole in
more and more income going to capital
and especially after generation
generation potentially leading to
dynastic wealth but the one thought
experiment once again I my goal here
isn't to give my point of view it's
really to just give you things to think
about and for you to come to your own
point of view is is to think about the
comparison between the present day and
the Gilded Age which the book makes if
we look at the Gilded Age so let me
write this here so the Gilded Age so
this is the end of the 19th century the
late 1800s the Gilded Age what were the
what were the forces of growth in the
Gilded Age where was a lot of the income
being generated from well this was
really the peak of the Industrial
Revolution you have things like
railroads railroads you have oil I guess
you could say you know energy oil you
have manufacturing manufacturing all of
these industries are incredibly capital
intensive capital is very important you
can't even do these things without
capital and in all of these labor is a
bit of a commodity that hey you just
need people to kind of you know nail the
the railroad ties in and things like
that you need people to just you know
work on the rig you need people to work
on the assembly line and the Industrial
Revolution was really a process of
taking these crafts and turning them
into more and more you know one-off
almost you could call it commodity labor
now let's think about the present day
and we could probably I think it's fair
to call it the information age
information information age and what are
the what are the growth industries in
the information age well one that's
close to my heart I'm making this video
in the middle of Silicon Valley is
software actually that's that's part the
one that really stands out to me is a
major growth area but there's you know
kind of bio tech biotech we could go on
and on and on and what's common about
all of these well they're not
necessarily as capital intensive as what
we see here in particular for
about if we're talking about software
it's not very capital-intensive at all
you just need some computers and a place
to program and you could in theory do it
inside someone's house and this is
really more about highly highly highly
skilled labor
same thing with biotech it does need
capital but that capital isn't for
railroads and or it isn't for you know
hugely I mean there is some equipment
but it's mainly for people it's mainly
for researchers and people to run the
clinical trials and and and for whatever
else and so we are it seems like we are
in an age where labor is going to become
more and more invaluable more valuable
but not just commodity labor not just
someone to kind of you know work one
shift at the factory but highly highly
highly skilled labor
now just because this is happening this
more because this is happening this
could be a driver of more and more
income going to labor but that by itself
wouldn't necessarily drive off
inequality for example you might have a
situation and there's some date signs
that maybe it's this happening where if
you look at if this is the pool of folks
that the people who are able to
participate in this these high-growth
sectors where labour adds a significant
amount of value that that's actually a
small percentage of this population so
the small percentage of the population
is going to take advantage could
potentially take advantage of these and
if of these dynamics but if the rest of
the population doesn't have the skills
necessary then they're going to
essentially be left out of this growth
and so that could still drive inequality
it won't be driving inequality because
of income going to more an income going
more and more to capital because of our
being greater than G because returns of
capital or greater than growth it
wouldn't be because of that it would be
because of this differentiation and
labor we're highly highly skilled labour
is getting a disproportionate share of
the income relative to other labor so
the question is is can we get more
people to participate this and once
again this is an issue of education can
we get this pool as a percentage of the
population to become a much larger pool
of the population so more and more so
more and more of the
world more and more of the world can
participate in that so once again this
is just something to think about I don't
know the answer to this but there are
some dynamics in play and we're
definitely in a different type of world
than we were in the Gilded Age another
way that you could think about it and
this isn't from the book but this is
just a way that I sometimes think about
it if you think in the industrial
revolution you have the world was kind
of a the world was kind of a pyramid
that down here you have your labor then
and you use a lot of folks there but it
was relatively unskilled and then in the
middle you kind of have your
white-collar jobs you could white-collar
jobs you this is the folks who are kind
of manipulating information filing
papers etc etc the office jobs and then
at the top of the pyramid during the
during the Industrial Revolution really
going into the 20th century you had you
had a I guess you could say your capital
owners your owners of capital and then
you had also very small you had a very
small I would say creative class so this
is creative creative creative class and
so this would be folks like this would
be folks like engineers and artists and
people doing research and so this this
is essentially the dynamic you had but
now when we go into the Information Age
automation is making labor is making
labor less important and even
white-collar jobs information processing
and so there's a there's there's two
different realities that we could
potentially go to there's one where
essentially you have you still have a
relatively small class of people who own
capital or own most of the capital or in
a creative class and then you have a
small you have a actually let me just so
if I just take that triangle that same
triangle right over there so you still
have so you still have a small group of
people who fall into the top of the
triangle and because automation is
taking care of these middle to you only
the small sliver of people who are
participating in here and so everyone
else here
is essentially going to be left out so
these folks are going to be left out
which isn't a good recipe for anyone but
there's another there's another reality
where well what if we could expand this
top triangle where we can have a larger
and larger creative class and if these
people can participate in the high-value
labour jobs I guess you can say then
they are going to be in a position to
capture more and more of the income and
then they will also be in a position to
have more and more capital you see that
happening in Silicon Valley you know
people who get a neat software job at
Google or Facebook or Apple not only you
know they're getting that through their
labor but because that that income is
larger than their expenses their start
they're able to start to accumulate
capital and also become capital owners
so there's a reality that if we play our
cards right in education and once again
this is close to my heart maybe instead
of going to this world where we leave
all of these people out we can go to a
world we can go to a world that looks
more like this where we don't need a lot
of Labor because of automation more kind
of I guess you could say commodity labor
we don't need a lot of kind of the
traditional white-collar jobs
information processing and then most
people if we can get education to be
good enough can now participate in these
really high value jobs where labor has a
lot more leverage where the returns to
labor are larger than the returns to
capital and because the returns to labor
are larger
you're going to have those people also
they're going to get more share of
income and they're also going to be able
to start to accumulate capital so
getting to this reality where you're
having a larger and larger percentage of
people who are essentially capital
owners capital owners and software
engineers and artists and people doing
R&D in my mind this is predicated on
improving on improving education so to
get from here to here and to avoid going
to this top one it really is about about
having a more a more talented labor pool
or more educated labor
Poole and if we pull this off then we
get into what would be considered kind
of a Star Trek reality a Star Trek
reality people don't really view Star
Trek from economic point of view but in
Star Trek you might realize that there
aren't a lot of people kind of tilling
the fields here there aren't a lot of
people just kind of doing desk jobs at
Star Trek everyone in Star Trek is
either doing R&D there are explorers or
they are or they are artists so once
again just something to think about that
education that knowledge dissemination
could be a very very powerful force of
convergence and keep us from going into
another Gilded Age